[Music]
i think people say i look a bit like a
queen in this outfit
and people call me your majesty
people come up and they curtsy it's
almost like living two lives really
let's commence
[Music]
i'm ella slack and i'm the queen's
standing
i've done it for over 30 years now
anything that the queen does
is rehearsed
if it's just going to a town hall or
opening
a hospital i've probably been a stand-in
queen definitely more than 50 times
a stand-in is not a look-alike i don't
look like the queen but i'm the same
sort of stature and height
i'm about virtually five foot the
queen's about five foot two but i live
at royal court
on queen's promenade
in royal ramsey in the isle of man and
the queen
lives in buckingham palace
in london i drive
a ford gear automatic car the queen has
been seen to drive range rovers and most
of the time
she's in a chauffeur-driven car or in a
carriage
well it started because i was at the bbc
and the producer who was doing the
cenotaph came to see me and said that
the queen had sent a message to say when
she stood at the cenotaph the sun was in
her eyes
and so could we do anything about it
well i said to him would you like me to
come and stand in the position for you
because all the stage managers were six
foot men and then that led on to other
things i went in her royal carriage and
rode on the boat up to the tower of
london
and then there will be the state opening
of parliament
i've never been allowed to sit on on the
throne
in the house of lords i have to lurk
above it it's a very strict rule
if i'm in a carriage or a car i will
wave you know
like that it's like that
like that
the events that i've been helping with
are events that are transmitted
worldwide and millions of people are
going to watch
i look afterwards and watch the
programmes going out and i'll see her
there
and think i did it for you
you